each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
so projects but before I start I'd like
to give you a high-level overview of
some of the work that's going on my
group so you expect to see at least
eight we have a wide spectrum of
computing devices and reaching all the
way from very large is the club very
small which is smartphones tablets and
embedded computer devices and the bigger
we have this connecting piece you get up
web browsers applications that help us
connect from the cloud could be to be
embedded in the smartphone world so the
work that goes on might grow it is very
broadly speaking computer security and
software issues in all three of these of
the aspects of the spectrum so I just
listed over here are the three broad
areas as well as a few sample questions
that investigators are oh so the cloud
you know we look at security issues we
are also looking at at issues of how to
create apps better for the club we have
worked on browser security issues when
recently concluded project we studied
browser extensions it can be issues and
we are also looking at security and
software engineering so I get all of
this hopefully engage of the stock I
think a little bit about each one of
these projects do you highlights about
specific results to be here but for
today's I'm just going to focus on the
first date here which is the club so of
course you know these days it's
fashionable to talk about the cloud and
you know every companies it can have its
cloud offering or
three weeks and so you know you say
Cloward you seem smart right so that's
what this title here says but you know
back when this motion of clubs started
becoming popular 2008-2009 event that's
what the few of my colleagues write I
asked them what's that love so each one
would give me a different answer some
people who say look gives Gmail and
Hotmail that's one of the flowers some
other people would say look it's these
huge data centers others would say look
you know it's Google Drive and those
kinds of things so pools right right so
everybody seems to be describing this
notion of a cloud in a different plane
but it turns out they're all right that
the one is driving the same thing but in
different ways depending on from the
experience so what is the club for the
purposes of today's talk so let me just
broadly define the cloud as a
distributed computing infrastructure
managed by some third parties and we
entrust our code and data with these
third parties yes that's what they
notion of a cloud platform is going to
be for today's flow and of course I'm
going to be purposely paid because I'm
just going to give you examples of what
the cloud and as you can see here the
cloud comes in many flavors right
infrastructure of the service big abysus
of service platform as a service so how
many flavors of this I don't necessarily
need to talk about the economic benefits
in this is fine this menu right here
about you know why it's good to go on
the clock but what can we talk about
this public versus private cloud
infrastructures because participation
very useful for the dog so by public
cloud services I mean things like Amazon
or Microsoft sure where third parties
can come and rent computation time from
these syllables from the company and
post a comment and run their computation
there this is as opposed to private from
infrastructures there for example banks
and so on run their own many data
centers and come here to computations so
I'm going to be mostly concerned with
public cloud infrastructures but some of
what I talk about applications and so
very broadly speaking when I talk about
a cloud this is the picture I have it
one so we have a data center with a
large number of physical machines each
one of which has some computer which we
have a hypervisor layer and Christ can
read computation time and so what they
do is they get virtual machines on which
they can contain parameters now every
such platform also comes together with
its own management solution this is
typically called Dom 0 and this
management virtual machine is the one
that runs all the scripts for access
talking Bien's shutting down the airs
migrating VMs resource consolidation all
that runs within doxy so think about
this in some sense as a group user of
the entire plan so it's got
administrative privileges into whatever
it wants is complete the villages over
any one of these workflow solutions if I
inspect its memory it has it runs device
drivers and the physical part and this
is the prototypical example of the cloud
on Amazon
you're open / expectancy and so on so
the management bouncier as well at the
hypervisor in the heart better water and
format it not provided whether the work
bunch of machines belong to the clamps
so so what's the problem
right so if computing exists today so
why are more people not going to that so
I argue that there are two main problems
that prevent you from going to the cloud
and posting their computations that the
first problem is that flag code and data
secrecy and inequity are vulnerable to
attack right so when a client goes on a
personal cloud provider to his circus of
computations or implicitly the planet
trusted provider will all get good and
evil but what's also happening is that
when the client does this is also
implicitly custom the cloud
administrators with all of his power
wouldn't become so cloud happens
traitors are employees of the clock
provider more responsible for day-to-day
operational control okay so that trust
rocks at them becomes implicit when you
sign in Italy with the combine so does
like that this is bad right but this can
keep your data breaches just two weeks
ago I was reading this article about
Microsoft spying on its employees for a
fail account for whatever reason so I'm
not sure that's the best example to give
about that it's an important example
like well there was an article about at
Google in points spying on on children's
data and he was fired for that and the
NSF Snowden data leaks but also an
example of administrators spying on data
that they should
so all of these reasons are the main
reason why enterprises like banks and
other financial trading houses are
reluctant to go to public infrastructure
the post wave populations so that's the
first problem security advice there is
another problem which is that guys who
sent their own complications to the club
they must rely on the cloud provider to
provide good customer services so you
know where the last 10 to 15 years of
virtual machine research there's been
quite a bit of work on virtual machine
introspection right you can do all sorts
of fancy security services hypervisors
I'll give you an example of it shortly
you can do memory consolidation if you
know all sorts of optimizations the
point is if you're going to do this on a
cloud you need the cooperation that are
provided right so this simple example
this client wants customized malware
detection and virtual machine remove
that ok but the top of either is only
going to give you checkpointing because
that's what it has implemented and you
know the client has no option but to
just go before the cloud provider gives
you so all of this research in over the
last 10 to 15 years of virtual machine
introspection it has no role unless the
cloud provider decides to deploy it so
that's the problem that we want to solve
and we want to get the clients more
power to deploy the kinds of services
that they want and I will argue that all
of these problems arise because the
cloud
- all right so the provider proposed the
management interface controls the
hypervisor whether the virtual machines
are all targets and so they are just
good Kirby's their worker drones running
the computations but they have no say
over the platform okay so let me give
you one example to show you these two
problems in practice and that example is
that art and architecture okay so I'm
going to talk about that over typical
example of virtual machine introspection
there the management PM runs security
checking FEMA is going to inspect the
client virtual machine for advanced kind
of of platform duties
okay so route cases are malicious
software that means that the operating
system and it's well-known that the only
way that you can protect these route
gives a very sort of reliable way is it
in a physical isolation from the machine
that's actually infected so in this case
you get that physical isolation through
the hypervisor and the management PM is
going to run the checking software so
checking software the way they work is
by grabbing memory pages from the
virtual machine that needs to be
inspected and you know you can do
whatever you want to see the the memory
pages you can hash them and check them
against some database or you can check
some variants of these databases
whatever you want you can do right
they're not specifically concerned with
the security policy but that guess you
fetch this pages from the plant virtual
machine to the management here that
happens through the hypervisor and then
you process the page when you cash it
amongst any variant X and you check it
against your security policy and if you
find a violation you stop the client
virtual machine otherwise you simply
continue with the execution okay so this
is how most virtual machine
work now we can see both of these
shortcomings in action so if you want
such such manner education on the clock
but number one you have to rely on the
cloud provider to deploy that checking
software in the management we have
within the dom 0 and the cloud provider
says no you have no option but to Salem
I won't get that kind of credential
element and the second problem of course
is that the cloud provider the cloud
administrator could be malicious and he
could snoop on all of the pages that
come from the times VM to the management
here thereby compromising the secrecy
integrity of the other clients Transco
haneda so him and this is why it should
be
it could be hard left so this management
we had put start another BM designate it
as the recipient of these pages and you
know you can check everything there but
the point is that if the management game
that does the designation will be a
client the client cannot do it he
doesn't have the privileges the heckler
was a bit different to pass the that's
right
so however by such standard otherwise
just will give you their checking
whether the client is malicious oh
that's right if you're checking whether
to cry in fact it this would be either
you know the client wants to be the
provider to check whether it is infected
by the learning some regularity
compliant software to check whether the
yes you can do a nesting you can do
testing as well but you do nest him you
can get this you can you can
services you won't get the security
benefits but let me show you is a
solution that gets you put the security
benefits as well as the extension the
dimensions you can grind you up your
you're checking demon with it the
transport solution with the hypervisor
player they are using Nestle and Shane
right but you still will not get
security because we are the management
p.m. of the base hypervisor can simply
limit so you can get one or the other
component and there are networks that do
this using nested yes so you need not
even be a volitional administrator in
fact you can have personal management
teams software stack as well as manic
advisor that essentially gives you the
same benefit that have the same effect
as as as a malicious code metrics
trainer
right so the management we have
indicated on the full-fledged operating
system with complex scripts and so on
which have a large number of bugs has
documented a few here there are at least
around 50 documented bugs in the
management VM a popular software stacks
and you can exploit these using things
like buffer overflows and get complete
control over the management here and
thereby compromised my clients virtual
machine ok so that also possible even if
you don't necessarily think of your
administrators as being malicious so
what I'm to propose is a solution for
self-service opportunity where the
overall idea is going to be to reduce
the prevalence of the management
and you increase the privileges of the
clients prohibition okay but this is far
from trivial but you just kind of say
I'm going to take away everything of a
management team and give it to plan for
solution after all the cloud providers
still want to be in control of the plan
okay so the intricacies in how to do
this properly and I'm going to describe
the solution which is very fairly simple
but actually valuable for the kinds of
applications that it enables which I
will also discuss but first let me just
talk a little bit about that one
yes so on a cloud I would like to
distinguish between two kinds of enemies
two kinds of that person the first is of
course of providers these are entities
like Microsoft Google Amazon and so on
who have a vested interest to protect
their depredations it so you when you
take your computations to Microsoft you
sign an SLA with Microsoft so you trust
Microsoft as a name and of course the
provider employs administrators to take
care of day-to-day operations of the
cloud so platforms when you put the
clock provided you essentially trust the
provider as well of that ministry so
that's the corner of the menu when you
get away from black box the other
extreme is of course where you choose
not to trust the provider you choose not
because the administrator there are
solutions there solutions such as
homomorphic encryption which are you
know still topics of active research and
it's going to be a while before they're
active they're able to be practically
used so I love you for our bottle where
we sort of choose an intermediate threat
model that we trust the cloud provider
and then you clarify the matter
I'll shortly but we don't trust that
ministry okay so the administrator the
game today operated for that model not
trusted he still trusts the cloud
provider and that's where the clear
solution so the implication of this is
that we cannot protect against certain
class of attacks so for example if the
provider gets a subpoena from the
government to go and monitor specific
clients who their data we cannot protect
against them something like cryptography
solutions using homomorphic encryption
can give you that get we cannot yes
administration No so again if
administrative interface is going to be
requested the providers will be trusted
in the sense that the hypervisor and it
will check that different types of
analysis will start using the using
using a trusted platform module so we
don't rely up there with administrated
interface at all you can have offer
workflow there nothing is well the
provider is just going to give you basic
hardware as well as the hypervisor and
it's going to start the management
interface the management interface will
be run by the administrator the
management interface has been at
demonstrate shortly with have no
privileges of flagships
so you can have whatever you want to
protect ourself the hypervisor is still
trusted so the hypervisor if you have
some sort of a bug then yes right so
then it's vulnerable to all sorts of
attacks as people but the management
interface is the big problem
birthdays are 150 thousand lines of code
the management VM is around a million
lines of code and you can have smaller
types of places there are you know
hypervisor that's when that's going to
be the solution
I tell you so the key is how to do that
and so the administrator can modify the
hypervisor okay but only when you can do
that is by using a firmware update
actually yes we modify the entire
software step so he married us right we
can check that the hypervisor has been
modified using the classic platform
module we take a software every time
machine just a brief outline of the talk
I talked about the basic solution model
which is this application and then you
privilege model which enables our
computing more simple solution but I
talked about the key technical
challenges that came to overcome as well
as the application that it enables and
the very brief in my experimental
evaluation is special discussion paper I
just woke up and I guess within and
about directions and if time permits the
first of other problems so let's just
look at the management VM and what kind
of things that it does on a regular run
so I would say that the dom0 has two
broad responsibilities the first is to
manage and multiplex hardware resources
so for this advanced device drivers and
so on and if also has all the scripts to
manage bank virtual machines resource
allocation starting shutting down
everything is entrusted to the
management team so in our solution had a
high-level here's what we do we create
two kinds of administrative interfaces
there is one system-wide management
domain which is which is the interface
that's available to the cloud
administrators we call that s Tom zero
and every client gets gets his own on
work client management p.m. so if I
start a virtual machine on the club and
I'm not right I get my room and
iterative interface for that virtual
machine as well as any other virtual
machine for Islam and I call those few
dogs use okay so the s non zero it
manages the hardware and it does not
have access to climb virtual machines we
do this by modifying the hypervisor and
so it's all first problem that of
security and privacy any time this
virtual machine transfer access the
memory or map the memory of a client
virtual machine it's not going to be
permitted access and the client
management virtual machine they give
every client administrative access over
that clients virtual machines okay so
that client can now other ready
transaction virtual machine that he can
start up that inspect the memory state
of everyone
okay so that gives clients the ability
to deploy new services from their own so
that solves the problem of greater
control over the client for solutions
and this is not just a random thing that
we did in order to you know achieve
these to those but rather what we did
improves the security of the hypervisor
on the cloud platform by making it
actually two core security principles
which is the principle of separation of
privilege okay and the principle of
least privilege of separation of
turbulence is that you separate the
principles as as you mean and you give
each principle just that the amount of
privileges that it needs to accomplish
the task that that is X okay so s12 zero
now only has to complete this blacks a
start where no longer has the privilege
is to top the flag for two regimes and
to inspect their memory
you don't zero can just do that but it
cannot access factor okay so we have
essentially improve the security of the
platform but that's technically VMs are
being affected that's right but this
just doesn't allow you say the cloud
provider check their clients that's
right
so I will get to an abstraction called a
mutually trusted service to me that will
give you exactly that that kind of
ability
okay so I'll get to that in a few slides
from now but
they say there's a system you won't have
the favorite sector 7g maybe that's when
so how does it perform sweetness
multiplexing of is okay doesn't have
access to memory right it still has
access to this I know who networked and
so on
but now if you want to protect network
communication each plan you can just
insert the traffic before it makes a
stop sale
so it can still do all of the network so
people don't you come zero does very
taxing be energy high-density right so
if it doesn't have a mapping axis right
that's a very good point right so what
into this there is a model so we did all
of this within them so there is a model
here within the Dom zero I forget the
exact name it's called it's not a paper
so that basically that module it maps
all the devices to individual domains
and we had to also do something besides
negation over there I'm not talking
about it here it's in our paper I forget
the name of that module and so it's
running but you're right
that's a very good observation what I
show you here is the very simplified
view your closer to them so let me just
summarize what an SSD platform moves
like it so I could summarize all the
abstraction have talked about we have
Hardware in the top that we have this
SSE hypervisor which is the special
hypervisor HX privileges whenever of the
s non-zeros the use of zeros on top of
this it has a s nauseam every physical
platform and its own nest or 0 that's
managed
that's responsible for managing our vet
and every client gets his own two thumbs
you again the client can start a number
of what virtual machines to do there
whatever computations they want and now
let's say that client wants to inspect
the state of the virtual machine using
one of those Mad Men detection
techniques I spoke about he can start a
service p.m. and give it privileges over
specific workflow solutions okay
so he can do it using new dog zero as
well but we follow the principle of of a
separation of turbulence and is
privileged to the extreme in the sense
that you can delegate service peon to do
this possible and this collection of
virtual machines is called a client
method OE so every client the method
remain looks like this against one year
dot zero possibly multiple service VMs
possibly multiple virtual machines and
the whole thing is called a planetary
and the important thing to note is that
s dom0 cannot inspect the memory state
of any one of these type virtual
machines okay and that can be multiple
clients so you can have various
computers per post the fiber
you know they you don't sit on the
service fee and belong to that their
decline so so from the clients
perspective that's fine that's actually
he loved it then at that point clear on
the planks so if there's a buffer
overflow here somebody exploits the
vulnerability here
that's absolutely right process this is
prospect for where I'm not sure I would
go that far right so what did they meet
my trusted code this is the high school
right so he has reason to believe that
this one is not religious right all of
the center clients go so this is the
clients administrative interface the
client service virtual machine clients
virtual machines he can run whatever he
wants you he can run you know software
that's very fine detail grant software
vulnerabilities that's that's his
heading the cavity that we give you so
whether you as a client want to check
that okay
you can run that as a service for
solution okay so you can just start off
that memory page detection software and
you can run it yourself over here what I
haven't told you about is feathered
right when the cloud provider wants to
check whether you're running man for
example
so so this is yes but the power
overflows happen within the management
that's the vulnerable influence this is
a fairly small attack surface hypervisor
responses what you think bouncing yes no
that's the dog zero is the big one and
so the client does not trust their stock
see he trusts their dog did on the sense
that he trusts it not to launch denial
of service attacks for example this s
Thompson who can drop all that put
packets that come from here then the
client will know something's wrong but
he trusts he does not have to trust as
dom0 the sense that you know he's not
entrusting it to run malware detection
services from his
I've got a box in progress you know the
box it is the clients eyes the clients
boundary all of these are not machines
no all of these collection of clients
being so you know he if the client is on
desk on the track so everything outside
of this does not belong to the find a
advisable obstacle provider s comes you
know belongs to the corner point oh this
belongs to you so that's the boundary we
go yes you don't zero then yes big or as
small as you want right so you can run a
huge software stack here or you can run
mini os/2 hypervisor it's a virtual
machine it's a it's a dog zero so it has
I think each and every point is not
eaten right each other you type in your
credit object right and then here
suppress someone else you have certain
very good point so I'm going to talk
about an app model right so if you have
a technically sophisticated plan you can
write whatever you want here otherwise
you know you can't download something
that's existing then but the point is
you're cool right so what you're trying
to protect yourself here from is the
cloud provider the chloride crystal okay
so this is like saying I am running
bother about software you know can I get
that of course you can
right but what's your network that model
there is your own traffic lock the white
and the town administrator now so you
don't you trust a provider for every
state this interfaces are trusted
very hard to do these things are an
excess of 10 million OS you've got zero
can be much smaller because not not it's
not running device failures so one thing
you can do here is that you can run this
software for mini OS which is a small
suppress and plus importantly it's
gateless it does not have to maintain
any state if there is any crash just be
started so that's the advantage of
having a separate mm completely status
alright so this is the privilege model
just be curling every time you have a
privileged operation from of the end you
they close ourselves will sacrifice will
checks whether the request is from the
you down zero if so you allow the
operation on the client solution if not
you check whether it's coming from the
service virtual machine the regulations
to do so if so allow otherwise you do
not so the path that has drawn zero
would take
no no pop so it cannot expect any other
client solutions so now let me explain
pretended technical challenges that we
had to encounter that being governed
intervene into solving this mystery so
the first thing is that providers want
some control yes oh if I was to think
what I just proposed in Google Blog
provided they would love it they are not
going to want to just give me complete
control over my virtual machines without
having absolutely no control over what's
your plan so for example this they need
to reinforce regulatory compliance when
I sign an SLA I would Amazon Microsoft
they expect me not to use their platform
for neither hosting so they have to have
some way of enforcing this when it is an
abstraction called the mutual interest
rates that is p.m. and can empathise and
then I'm also going to tell you related
challenge instead of building the
maintain and transport discussion like
you when you for the cloud you provide
the virtual machine image ask me the
cloud provider component but now the
cloud provider the s non zero is the one
that rivals so transportation how you
talking sort of you ensure that your
machine is moving time so I described
the secure bootstrap protocol that
enables that problem so let me first
tell you about mutually trusted service
virtual machines right so I just gave
you this example the language that cloud
provider and he says I don't want any
bit annex of corruption so you better on
the SSD hypervisor the talk / - case
okay fine but you know you should not
use my plot for illegal activities of
botnet asleep okay so the problem is is
you can just take what I described so
far and the best
do not expect the virtual machine today
you know the provider can expect over so
machines you can quite inspect the
memory data the poor in the data
everything in them say look you know
you're running that for pictures and
evidence of them so now the problem is
that s Tom's you know the club provided
the car administrators interface has
absolutely no visibility was running
into in the client virtual machines so
malicious clients can misuse this
privilege so we for a mutual interest of
this virtual machine which is a special
virtual which is the closest follows
it's a virtual machine that runs within
the clients meta domain ok but it
started using a special protocol between
the cloud provider network if so this
mutually trusted service VM for example
can be a malicious software detection
tool that checks clients virtual
machines and make sure that there are no
botnets running ok so some policy that
they provide the past may be the essays
and the talk provide around-the-clock
client have agreed that this is the SAT
ok so the client has agreed to run it
and so I divided the client engagements
protocol and start at the situation now
this virtual machine starts off with the
transmeta to me okay
but unlike the regular service p.m. its
execution is locked by the SSE Hydra
person in the sense that the client do
not shut it or modify it once it starts
execution ok this is a hypervisor will
ensure that and what and what this does
and important to notice that esto 0 no
longer has access to the memory of this
mutually customer solution so this
mutual trust
to run bunch of policy checks from the
Transworld pollution and report back
stream of a stream of things in so the
semantics of the stream of bits is that
it should be only zeros if the line is
is not violating they're sending the
minute that plan violates the SLA it
will send that a 1 ^ ID okay so at this
point a cloud provider has absolutely no
idea what the club client is running but
they can still get magnetic compliance
enforcement through this mutual customer
service resolution okay he has no
visible again what's there but he gets
that results from the specific virtual
machine which was started using this
protocol that the cloud provided at the
clock client engagement so what this
abstraction also enables is an
application that's not possible under
its pros which is that of mutual a
trusted resource accounting okay so
here's the problem
checks out yes how do you trust that
this
go there so both the job provided on the
client agree upon the software that's
going to not for example it could be an
encoded version of the SLA that there
are no water is running this is the
software that's going to be checking
that you know there are no water running
okay that's the best part they're
selling you encode that in this virtual
machine and you engage in this protocol
to start it on that purple or
non-standard
start it up as a really classic service
social shape the the the guarantee that
they have the bus it gives you is that
execution is locked in the sense that
the client cannot shut it or modify it
once it starts execution so this part in
the original custom service we have in
this is to machine and precise back to
be a sponsor because all you need here
is a boolean right so whether you're in
violation of the SLA or not right so if
you are violation of yesterday you get
back a report to the provider gets back
the pig say we plan to smile at with the
SLA if they say is not violated for the
time to provide of the season
so this example solution actually fit
this one then you know you know that all
providers cheating okay
that's absolutely right right so in
terms of the schematics of the stream
that's guaranteed side channels are
another issue but that's why we say that
both of cannot provide on the client the
onus is on them to ensure that you know
they agree for the software that's right
around like this may involve food on it
or whatever and then you start up the
code and at that point you know that
that's the code that go to change from
regulating
it gives you the yes yes yes is starving
yes but then we totally popper over
frozen love you okay
they say about the text which was
all communication goes here right all
communication goes to the driver over
here that's right that's right
I know there you know that you cannot do
right the reason you cannot do that is
because once you start it so let me just
answer the questions one by one thing so
your concern was you started it okay and
you're not going to disable it before it
ever cross seems the reason you do not
shut it down because the shuttle also it
was a protocol between the client and
so right so that that's a good solution
I mean it could be for regulatory
compliance for example absolutely so the
next example I'm going to give right so
what we have in mind are other
applications of mutual interest rate
service virtual machines one of which
I'm going to spread out resource
accounting so the point is more in those
services as you have you do not know the
story
which is my sort of factor it out its
own virtual machine but for the specific
purpose of of regulatory compliance I
think you can do it with life ever since
I was born
that's right that's right forward yes
yes so for this specific case you are
absolutely right to generalize let me
just so the communication that means as
we collect so the communication over
here right so for every boat so machine
you have drivers that connect from from
here to a driver here if so at least
from then that's the case then is a back
and a front end right here that both
connect with each other therefore on for
all the communication okay so now what
you're saying is what if this guy drops
our packet right how can you drop the
packet only then you can drop the packet
is that the driver has been corrupted
over here and the over the data of this
mutual interest or is VM unlocked by the
hypervisor so you cannot drop a packet
unless your tampered with the driver
that comes with mutual respect service
for solution which P which we start off
to protect using SSA never buys it so
that's not possible then I gather
structure attacks will have a chronic
talk about this but at least this
particular attack is protected against
because the driver cannot be one
so here is an interesting application on
this thanks to mutual custody source
economy so to be a wreck if you go to
the cloud provider right you get paid at
the end of the day for your network
consumption your CPU cycles consumes and
so on you essentially pass the clock
provider into be whatever the cloud
providers ask you to be you can also run
your own checking software right you can
run your own resource accounting
software and check that because of
certain other network traffic that you
consume is sort of matches up with what
the cloud provider gives you but what's
there for this much and what if what you
are saying differs from what the cloud
providers is telling your billing you
for who do you go you know who is right
that you do you approach and how do you
resolve such conflicts so with mutual a
trusted service PMS you have a nice way
to solve this problem right so the top
provider and the cloud client can agree
upon the resource accounting software
for example the software transfer of
lights that starts with it I can start
this up as a mutual interest except this
virtual machine and at the end of the
day because you started this is a
mutually personal service what the cloud
provider as well as the client have
reason to trust the aquadolls
ok so whatever the outputs are the
number of bytes of CPU cycles you
consume you just pay for me right so in
some sense Trust is built into the
internet into the static of the virtual
machines so that's one of the
applications of of mutual trust this
special kind of power solution
so let me just tell you about how it
below means right I spoke about s from
zero and building virtual machines to
you know like the neutron zero and so on
but what I think what I didn't tell you
about is that most of this building
building happens through a trusted
virtual machine called the domain
builder domain builder is the one that
is responsible for actually accepting
virtual machine images from clients we
starting it out and it's the one that
talks were custom platform module and
ensure that the correct virtual machine
is started and so whenever the clients
gives a virtual machine talks to the
commended through the a strong zero
which of course contains all of the
network drivers and he gives the image
that the main builder and that he starts
up the Yukons you okay that's the first
thing that happens so every client has
to spot ok you don't see once you start
something you comes you he sets up an
SSL connection with this you know zero
and then transmits other images to the
street on 0 to start virtual machine
service question was shaken and so on so
so that's how the main blending proceeds
being the main base happens the you from
zero it also builds the other domains
but all of those virtual machine images
are transmitted to you come 0 through an
SSL connection so the key thing is
fergie established businesses and
connection so we can you about the
problem that appearance that that sort
of happens if you do this in a nice way
and
so bonus to play this you don't 0 ok and
establish an SSL connection with this
you don't you the business don't you
know controls the network it's in
complete control over the network you
can view modify anything that starts
with it over the net so the implication
of this is what we call an evil twin
attack whichever it is grab the next
time here so let me describe the attack
so here this a client he wants to build
his domain so it is got a be an image of
the you dom0
that it's sending over to the domain
better through the storms you so now
that the main data right
so the town administrator gets ahold of
this in terms you know you can get from
this clients trying to move this so
instead what he does is he takes his
four virtual machine half image which is
malicious in some way and gives it to
the domain later and the domain that
that beliefs this belongs you so now if
the client thinks that this Radames
negative response to his request and
private key with this becomes you know
then the end account administrator gets
four of the ssl priority which is an
undesirable scenario so the consequences
are that the client must establish this
ssl connection because you and the SSL
handshake require that the you don't you
actually could be this is a primary key
now the evil as I as I've shown you this
evil 12 you dom0 can send this key over
to malicious Brown administrator so what
we want to do is to come up with a way
to protect the secrecy of gains of the
class assistant credit and I'll show you
a protocol that that achieve this the
secure bootstrap protocol that
so here's idea it's the client starts
you come zero what not to start the you
come zero he sends the image over to the
domain so this is sent over the network
connection with the VDS rocks you know
and together with a non zero image he
also sends this piece of syphilis which
is fresh turkey and a random number
encrypted with the DBMS publicly okay so
at this point the domain builder creates
the domain okay it could be subject to
an evil twin attack we don't yet know
but the domain mentor just builds the
domain using this disk image that the
client came at this point that I make
builder goes and takes this piece of
separate X that was given in the first
step talks to the TPM and detects this
this piece of simple text and at that
point it has access to this symmetric
key as well as a random number which is
the chicken stops within the you dogs
you so by virtue of the fact that cannot
ESS in hypervisor this s bouncier can no
longer get the values of offices from
this key and the monks at the random
number so then the domain vendor it
measures the the software stack against
the attestation of the software's 13 sec
promise' and sent it over to the client
and also the client is satisfied that
the domain the correct domain was
started it sends the random number over
the plan this is to protect against
replay attacks and at this point the
client can simply send the SSL fire key
encrypted under this pressure symmetric
key yeah
so once this is done the you know 0 then
decrypt this message self-irony
install it within
which is no longer accessible to us from
zero and then you can engage in the
necessary action okay so once you engage
in a mr. sell and shake you have a
secure connection from the client of you
gone zero the client can send word for
the virtual machine students you know
that's our our specular bootstrap
protocol and how we protect the secrecy
of the SSM planet so the end of the day
this is what it looks like to our client
the client has a you don zero that's in
charge of its domain you have a whole
bunch of mutual interest rate service
virtual machines if you want that
regulatory compliance first for the
metering you have service virtual
machine that can run all sorts of inter
special services you can change storage
you can improve life on media boxes like
firewalls and ideas and you have
computation the word solution so we
implemented a whole bunch of services
using this technique right here
then storage services such as encryption
intrusion detection kernel level group
detection system common connection how
much of these around ten services I
won't get into all of them and just
highlight two of them for the purpose of
experimental evaluation the nice thing
is that you can actually compose these
services all you need to do is pass the
output of one as the the other so it's
just like composing two functions and
you get the benefit of more so this
briefly speak about our evaluation we
implemented this or cup of Z you have to
buy selfie and also KTM now on a CF CCS
per paper has a whole bunch of other
just going to show you two examples so
here's one it's a storage encryption
service where the client wants to
include all storage that's going to the
list and typically what you would do on
here on a resin system is that you can
implement this within the top device
device driver of the of the Tom's you
that terms with the device rather than
the client the end and wall encryption
come in scale you can do it like that in
SSC you would have storage encryption
service vm that runs in the clients
domain that does all the encryption and
talks based on scale so s proxy only
sees encrypted traffic ever played down
and here's the performance right so if
you said or if you do this in an
unencrypted fashion then the throughput
that you get with Xen is around 80 1.7
megabits per megabytes per second itself
services slightly lower because you have
one more level of interaction and if you
have a depiction to turn on encryption
the throughputs drop but so that's the
range encryption you can also as I said
you can compulsory system is one simple
thing that you can do right flank and
check point is virtual machines using a
checkpoint in service but the client may
decide that he wants encrypted
checkpoints and what you do is you pair
up your check pointing service with an
encrypted storage and you get it
checkpoints a service I'd given you some
performance numbers for that as well in
terms of encrypting and one to machine
so the encryption takes around one point
eight four seconds on a legacy platform
itself service makes my keyboard with
unencrypted whereas if you do encryption
get a slightly larger number so there's
a whole bunch more evaluation of people
I won't really talk about the killer and
I also skipper the special amount of
related work in the interest of talking
about something that they are currently
working on in this domain right so just
to summarize SSC is this cloud model
that improves credit by security and
privacy enhances jeans has a fairly
large number of applications so what we
are doing now is extending this to the
notion of glove that marks it so if you
look at what SSE enabled enables this
notion of service VMs that people give
this run on their virtual machines right
so imagine a world where clients don't
have to write this on their own but
rather Goodman app market just like
mobile app markets and download and
introspection app and run it on their
solution okay so that's the vision that
we have so where these services are
implemented by third parties and clients
can simply download them and use them
with the words between them two machines
and you do all of this without relying
on the cloud provider so it enables a
number of useful kinds of applications
Thanks so we have already on Amazon
today standalone apps you can get you
can actually purchase a virtual image
that's virtual machine image that's
pre-configured for let's say running web
services but it sustainable things like
cooperative apps right
able to read and modify the memory of
transports of machines you are able to
do forensics and of course you have
anything to compose these apps so within
the context of this we are looking at a
whole bunch of research issues you know
that is the security of third-party apps
just like you have security issues with
mobile apps today when you download your
platform the same issues will also arise
in this study so we are looking at you
know how could we check the security of
an app and how can we check that you
know it's not going to be client we have
any sort of it respects the clients data
you know software design issues you
right so how do you make these apps to
impose upon one API if you expose so
that you know it works better or it
works optically with other kinds of okay
and then we read apps without sacrifice
and level changes right so SSE kind of
advisor requires changes itself can you
do this without hypervisor level changes
the answer is yes using master puts
realization but you do some of the
benefits that assessing a bunch of
discussion about some other projects in
my group which I can talk about
individually strip just skip over that
but so I'll just conclude I take
questions with word of thanks to all of
my collaborators so that's it so let me
just take questions on this
go ahead yes yes myself can you can so
that's right right so but what I'm
talking about as apps and virtual
machines themselves and not talking
about a 95 is an executable submission
right that you can do today obviously
what you cannot do are a virtual machine
level things virtual machine translation
based services that's not possible today
that's what I need my programs here
virtual machine apps okay so these are
complete virtual machines package stuff
you know that run let's say a firewall
or or you know forensic app it's good to
check memory pages or duplication or any
sort of optimization component all those
things but because our trust is just one
aspect you can service VMs would be a
better example they get us the
recipients which apps they have not yet
figured out of the mutual trust you can
do regular services like the unity
detection example and all of those will
be contained within these apps right so
if you just want to run a user level
service that's obviously possible today
what's not possible is virtual machine
level services that's what is happening
that
this is just an equation that goes for
the generals which is not congruent by
each of his right excellent question
okay so that's the follow-up work that
we've already done right so this is
where give it extended this self-service
platform across multiple computing
across multiple hardware platforms right
so the key thing there is there are two
issues right so first is my mission
okay solo the client should no longer
have the ability to see comedy you come
zeroes you pass because it can map that
clock so it present an abstraction that
a layer over these futon zeros then that
fights this vegan the second is you know
securely communicate that's right so
that's what we do and he talked about
that him